bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous
également bon soir aux gens qui nous
suivent
là haut sur le live on a deux
congélateurs sur terre on a le pôle nord
les ours
et puis le pôle sud les pingouins et on
a également de nombreux glaciers qui
climatise et réguler la température de
notre planète
ma mission aujourd'hui devant vous c'est
de vous faire aimer le froid l'hiver la
glace et puis de vous montrer à quel
point les régions polaires sont des
zones fragiles qu'il faut protéger
alors oui j'ai la chance aujourd'hui
d'être explorateurs polaires et de vivre
de ma passion
sur cette photo il fait moins 32 on est
au pôle nord
j'ai froid je me les cahiers à vrai dire
pour rester poli mais la terre elle est
la chaux geffroy c'est très personnel
c'est temporaire est en fait au final on
s'en fiche
ce qui est important c'est que la terre
elle est là chaud aujourd'hui en
permanence alors pourquoi aurais-je la
motivation de traverser les 20 plus
grands glaciers de la planète à skis
ensemble avec mon héros d'adolescence et
partenaires d'expédition aujourd'hui
borg et ousland pour répondre à ça c'est
pas seulement le fun c'est fun mais
c'est pas seulement ça ça va au delà de
ça parce qu'aujourd'hui notre but c'est
de sensibiliser sur la fonte des glaces
avant d'arriver à devenir un aventurier
un explorateur professionnels tout a
commencé ici j'ai 4 ans et puis
j'explore dans cette bassine
ça n'a absolument aucun sens un jour je
vais voir mon père et puis on commença
par l'exploration ensemble et puis très
vite
mon père me dit vincent explorateurs
polaires
c'est pas vraiment un métier et je le
comprends il a fait de son mieux
il a voulu me protéger et je pense qu'il
a entièrement raison
mais j'ai quand même voulu suivre mes
rêves et je vous embarque avec moi en
patagonie
jusqu'ici tout va bien
j'apprends le métier de guide
d'expédition et puis les choses ont
commencé à se compliquer
je ne sais pas vraiment ce qui m'arrive
mais l'histoire derrière cette vidéo
c'est qu'un jour on marche avec des
crampons un sac à dos assez lourd sur un
terrain de glace et de roches bien
fracturé soudain dans une pente
j'ai un collègue juste au dessus de moi
qui perd son équilibre et son crampon
bien traversé ma chaussure de ski et
bien fracturé mon petit doigt de pied le
lendemain je suis incapable de remettre
mes chaussures de ski je fais un taille
la seule possibilité c'est d'emprunter
les chaussures de trekking de bourgueil
taille 47 pour que je puisse y
introduire mon pied en toute douceur on
fabrique un système de fortune parce que
quand on est dedans expédition n'a pas
de magasin pour faire des emplettes
donc on fabrique un système de fortune
et nous voilà repartis pendant 14 jours
en skiant 9 à 10 heures par jour j'ai
pas d'assurance a pas rapatriement donc
il faudra aller de l'avant dans ce genre
de terrain et dans ce genre de
conditions
[Musique]
alors pourquoi est ce que je vous
raconte cette histoire l'histoire de la
patagonie
et bien en fait c'est que moi après
cette expérience j'ai découvert les
ressources les ressources mentales
insoupçonnées que j'avais et en fait
quand on parle du changement climatique
est bien le poids de la responsabilité
est tellement écrasant que ça me paraît
vraiment insurmontable
et pourtant comme en patagonie
aujourd'hui avec le changement
climatique en avançant un ski après
l'autre et des fois ça peut faire mal on
peut arriver à faire des prouesses qu'on
pensait impossible et ça c'est pas
seulement moi qui lui en patagonie
on l'a en fait nous tous comme on a tous
un destin d'aventurier
quand on a tous un instinct de chasseur
cueilleur maintenant j'aimerais vous
emmener dans le passage du nord-ouest ce
fameux passage qui connecte d'un côté le
pacifique à l'océan atlantique en
passant par le nord du continent
américain
on a navigué là haut avec des collègues
norvégiens ont la traversée ce passage
en 25 jours il y a un an à peine
le norvégien a mis en scène la franchit
en trois ans la raison principale c'est
la fonte des glaces un ou deux degrés
d'écart
ici à lyon on voit pas vraiment la
différence mais dans les régions
polaires 1 ou 2 degrés d'écart de
température ça transforme la glace en
eau qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça veut
dire que soudain l'ours blanc il est
privé de son territoire de chasse
la banquise pour pouvoir chasser le
phoque
c'est exactement la même chose que si on
nous retirait tous les supermarchés ici
à lyon
en 2014 à l'initiative de borg et nous
avons démarré le projet ice legacy la
traversée à skis des 20 plus grands
glaciers de la planète
notre but explorer et documenter la
fonte des glaces sensibiliser sur
l'accélération du changement climatique
est également encouragé un activisme de
conservation pour la protection de ces
espaces sauvages
il faut savoir également que borg et
c'était mon héros quand j'étais
adolescent je lisais des livres après la
bassine bon qui s'est passé quelques
années après la bassine
je passais dans la bassine pendant dix
ans mais j'ai été adolescents et puis
j'ai commencé à lire des livres de bord
gais c'est aujourd'hui un petit peu lui
le père de l'exploration polaire et il
ya vraiment une transmission assez forte
et durant les dix dernières années il
m'a transmis un petit peu tout ce que
lui avait appris sur le terrain et
aujourd'hui j'ai la chance de revenir
dans tactik et surtout d'être devant
vous pour j'espère vous transmettre ma
passion pour ces zones sauvages et puis
peut-être qu'un jour on partira ensemble
en expédition polaire je suis pas y en a
il y en a il y en a dans la salle qui
aimeraient voir les ours blancs on peut
être partir ensemble ouais ça serait
cool hein ok c'est quelques ces quelques
dernières années
borg et moi on a traversé les trois plus
grands glaciers d'alaska
alors rien que de penser à tout gatx ça
me fait encore froid dans le dos rond
cette photo on l'a pas prise parce
qu'elle est bien marché sur instagram on
l'a prise parce que on ne devait passer
par ce passage c'était l'endroit le plus
safe qu'on avait trouvé cette crevasse
de profil vu d'en haut au dessus
elle ressemble à ça c'est exactement le
même endroit et on n'avait pas trouvé
mieux un jour dans tout match on a eu
très chaud dans les deux sens du terme
la chaleur est écrasante sur le glacier
les ponts de neige ont commencé à se
fragiliser
et borg est tombé deux fois dans de
crevasses le même jour je vous cache pas
que quand j'en parle j'ai le fameux
sature d'émotion quand je repense au
moment où je vois mon copain en train de
tomber dans un trou qu'est ce que ça
veut dire pour moi c'est qu'en fait leur
la chute en crevasse et la rupture d'un
pont de neige pour moi c'est la rupture
avec le réchauffement climatique c'est
la rupture entre l'homme et la nature
tous les locaux de l'alaska nous l'ont
dit il fait de plus en plus chaud chaque
année et c'est de pire en pire
ice legacy est un projet aventureux mais
également une cause notre but
aujourd'hui c'est de continuer à
prélever ces glaciers et à donner donner
ces échantillons à la communauté
scientifique
pour la petite histoire vous voyez ici
une plume qui est déposé sur un glacier
la plume d'un oiseau elle est sombre et
tout autour
vous voyez le trou en fait qui est
générée par la réflexion du soleil
aujourd'hui avec tout le carbone qu'on
envoie dans l'atmosphère on peut
clairement se poser la question quelle
est notre part de responsabilité dans la
fonte des glaciers
bon ça peut être barbant ça mais on va y
aller tranquille les deux couleurs le
rouge
c'est tout le co2 qui adorent atmosphère
le bleu c'est les variations de
température on a une grande échelle à
peu près 650 mille ans on peut constater
qu'elles sont quasiment parallèle c'est
à dire qu'à chaque fois qu'il ya une
augmentation du co2 dans l'atmosphère
il y as en dessous une augmentation des
températures à chaque fois qu'il ya une
période glaciaire une la une la une la
on constate que la quantité de co2 est
réduit aujourd'hui on en est là donc on
a carrément explosé la moyenne et la
projection dans 50 ans on est là haut
donc pour moi ce graphe il veut
clairement dire qu'il ya une
intervention de l'homme dans
l'accélération du changement climatique
comment on peut établir une moyenne
avoir des cycles sur les 650 mille
dernières années on peut voir ces cycles
l'a bien clairement et tout d'un coup
depuis un siècle depuis
l'industrialisation
on constate que la courbe elle est même
plus exponentielle
elle est carrément verticale et moi je
crois vraiment ça je crois que vraiment
il ya eu une intervention de l'homme
dans tout ça bon j'arrête de vous
prendre la tête avec ça
pour moi la meilleure illustration de ce
dossier de ce graphe c'est les trois
dernières semaines qu'on vient de vivre
maintenant en france à biarritz il
faisait juste 27 degrés la semaine
dernière c'est vrai que c'est dur de
vous faire aimer l'hiver quand tu es 27°
à biarritz ok on va faire un petit
exercice ensemble si ça vous va moi je
vais fermer mes yeux et si vous le
voulez bien de les fermer également de
votre côté et je vais compter on va
faire un compte à rebours jusqu'à 5 5 4
2 1 sur cette photo cette photo il est 4
heures du matin on est en islande jeu
sur la berge
j'ai un appareil photo et j'attends que
le soleil réchauffe un tout petit peu
cet iceberg pour y distinguer des
contours et des textures complètement
incroyable c'est le plus beau le plus
bel iceberg que j'ai vu de ma vie et
dans ce genre de moment en voyant ce
genre de bijoux et ben je pense qu'on a
vraiment tous la responsabilité de
protéger protéger les espaces sauvages
il y a une autre histoire qui me tient
également vraiment à coeur c'est une
légende c'est un jour il ya un feu un
grand feu de forêt le bois s'embrase
tous les animaux sont dévastés doivent
quitter la forêt mais il ya un petit
gars un petit colibri qui voyagent entre
la rivière et le feu et qui fait des
allers-retours à chaque fois qu'il va
dans la rivière ils collectent un petit
peu d'eau ils voyagent ils volent au
dessus du feu et puis dépose cette eau
sur le feu un autre animal vient le voir
et lui dit mais pourquoi tu fais ça ça
va rien changer et le colibri lui dit eh
bien je fais ma part je suis petit mais
je fais ma part de responsabilité
et aujourd'hui je pense que vis-à-vis du
changement climatique on a tous une
responsabilité on est tous dans le même
bateau
y a pas de frontières et je pense que
c'est en faisant des petites choses
qu'on peut arriver à faire une
différence et à vivre dans un monde
meilleur
peut-être que vous le connaissez c'est
le fameux mouvement du colibri de pierre
rabhi et si on devenait des
consom'acteurs et si on devenait des
contributeurs plus que des consommateurs
quand on se promène dans les rayons d'un
supermarché et qu'on voit des mangas
vendre en plein hiver on peut se poser
la question que l'impact carbone et
énergétiques pour faire venir une mangue
du bout du monde jusqu'en france
elle est énorme et je pense que ça c'est
un petit exemple léger et je veux même
pas attaquer l'exemple de la viande
parce que pour moi ça me rend fou
quand on quand on élève quand on fonder
une famille et qu'on élève un enfant on
veut le protéger
quand noël arrive on a envie de le gâter
et lui offrir plein de cadeaux est ce
qu'aujourd'hui le plus beau cadeau qu'on
puisse faire à nos enfants c'est de leur
léguer un monde en bonne santé avec
plaindre ce blanc si un jour vous avez
des enfants
j'espère qu'ils auront la chance de
pouvoir devenir explorateur polaire en
mission pour protéger ces lieux magiques
et puis même s'ils veulent devenir des
jedi et bien au pire ils finiront
explorateurs polaires chez national
geographic
merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]